Hotel which scene in your latest film
the assassin are you most proud of and
why that's a 13 million pipes to 18
million I can drive you current
sweetheart always about sushi damn
target even canal 14 Tuffy was so
someone now chain yoga refer you who the
whole chow hall right journey to anistar
soul song alright young and eager to see
her a meal Toledo Nathan all that do I
would talk sweetie was a doubt lady so
sour so I said one part that I can think
of that like this the part where her
father has already been injured so
they're just hiding out like in the in
the village and in a farmhouse and she
was brewing medicine for her dad that's
thing and then she subsequently started
saying that you know she is very lonely
she's the only person of her kind
there's no one else like her and then
she even just got quite emotional and
she's delivering that line I think that
whole sequence I like quite a bit in
American cinema there is a phrase we'll
fix it in post
what are your thoughts on editing and
that phrase that make 102 think
generally reach your heart just what do
what do you think highly redundant went
in a ha maybe when she was 18 she also
carry about the going to jeju-do and
this is a my own kind India and in
Tunisia G Harlem
Donna the clip we are we also check
their BBC one the whole map I have
intelligent Tim Guang is all the energy
the energy are the material Jay today
Lucia can use more funds for me I
definitely agree with that statement
because for me if something is now
working I just cut it out
I cut out whatever is that don't like
and some people worry about continuity
but I feel like there's actually always
a way out
in terms of continuity you will figure
something out that was still somehow
making movie makes sense so I am the
strong believer in
editing I've read that you've said your
films are much more popular in Japan or
Europe why not in your homeland
say anything about technology it's in
Kosovo and so in Jenin depends sorry
also your hand open John Thank You Ben
no Quentin how much my haunted sincere
cordial saludo been to how I was about
how some quantum phenomena thought into
the Westerner Terran that keeping them
warm the Nick grinding the Cheney nd
when tom has issue and can howl I will
be she one can see using be a child
appeared know what happen
we are not Jeremiah if you know mature
may protect code the most halogen teach
ending were that age in quantum goodness
can capital G Quan Tiffany DL so yo that
is only information whatsoever though
change she was a my yeah okay that me
okay the face unchanged for know what a
Dana gender yeah I think it's difficult
because in Taiwan most people still
watch Hollywood movies other movies are
very popular in Taiwan and obviously how
Hollywood movies they tend to be more
dramatic
there's a lot going on it's very
heightened so for this generation of
moviegoers and spectators in Taiwan
that's the kind of movies they like and
this movie it took me several years to
make it so now I feel like I'm actually
dealing with even a newer generation of
audience whose taste is even harder for
me to grasp and who have even a set of
aesthetics and taste that's even further
removed from the previous generation so
this is a unique challenge for me and
it's something that I'm trying to figure
out cuz I feel like my movies could be
quite difficult for people for these
audiences
how does he feel that the new
generations tastes have changed as very
interesting encounters in juicy answer
is seeing that quanto new housing to me
I think that the answer using diagonal
current
tanda kokkonen to video cannon Josue a
ninja goes you gong jeongsun so
rescinded sapien can can companies can
bullion's Adhamiya contain the funds
here one Rubio Samar villain Romeo sweet
harmony on the 1970s Bhatia Tommy Oracle
may chair the human we contain change in
position until each equator say because
we came in some changes
tension well so much sunlen can observe
even cut so it's requiring the ship when
you were moving way cotton Tom Olympian
DeGeneres really see you and he doesn't
wanna see gran will Cap'n Cap'n them to
his hiney on the evil either equal it on
Tom the see how appear even I'm sure on
content and in pay and question and go
catch because I think the internet
actually has changed a lot of things
because I think this new generation
they're viewing habit is different
because they view a lot of stuff on
their device so the way people consume
media consume film is actually
fundamentally different from before now
I think people generally tend to be less
patient because you know they have they
can very easily choose whatever they
want and they can skip and stop and go
somewhere else
so if they decide not to watch something
whereas a movie especially going to a
theater and being a spectator with an
audience that requires a certain amount
of participation and patience and
endurance even but with this generation
of young people who just watch movies
and we didn't consume content on digital
devices I feel like they're probably
blast patient they can watch an entire
movie and come soon come to and like
riding the subway and watching stuff on
their cell phone so I feel like that's
one way in which the viewing habits
fundamentally changed and that's
creating new aesthetics and new
perception as well
of your career of your numerous movies
you've had a documentary made about you
you've had books written people theorize
about your filmmaking
we've been at con so many times what has
been the most greatest reward from the
whole journey of all of that
Singaporeans
Samaniego tomato sauce iguana Nina sue
endorser DNA DNA Oh EW pienso Cienega
Olivia's Abigail guanine dijo que toma
Dordogne Syrian issue became dense
decoder engineer dr. Vodafone bodega
Tigran say Angela to get some seed
intend on Tony Cheetara Soho today's Ojo
de trabajo de comedor
seed our Soho days Suchi what decisions
are tender helu Tahoe where total total
residual a Chandra Suresh Choudary
Ketchum dude
sir enchantress Turkish plane Rio Tinto
de volcán je vois send avoiding Cochise
Oh Sarah Jane no space where es lo que
yo hi danette a loser Oh Jay hi Asha is
astrology or Gonzaga's man and recent
dental centre origin so facial facial
someone Sierra de alta gracia Co
concealer look arranges geography on the
current Yahoo itself is it so it's PI
you attain the cabin
Jesus Tom super Hardy hotel it's a
diverse audience and also now we also
where a parent grantee Empire nurse well
taught Matsu over tests the Wickham
which had been shopping with us wherever
we enacted
yeah for me actually is simply been
about just choosing the path of movie
itself choosing to be a filmmaker and
that itself has been filled with joy
that has been rewarding because you
could say that through a lot of things I
wanted to make movies an early age and I
did end up making movies and I feel like
I did reach a certain level but
obviously when it comes to artistic
creation there any kind of artistic
expression
I feel like this shouldn't be an end
this shouldn't be like a limit to it
it's important for one to keep exploring
and keep moving forward and moving
further down so for me even though I am
68 right now I'm almost 70 actually
almost quite old but I feel like I still
have the same energy the same motivation
and I just want to keep pushing the
boundary keep moving forward and explore
the medium is cinema even further so for
example we were talking about digital
communication and the digitization of
cinema for me I actually want to explore
that for my next film I want to shoot on
digital camera and just to experience
beer just to experiment with that so I'm
someone who just wants to keep pushing
forward and I just keep going down this
path I believe in a documentary about
you hoedown it was done when you around
50 you your grandmother had gone to a
fortune teller and the fortune teller
said oh he is going to be a very
powerful man how much do you attribute
your career to luck and good fortune and
how much hard work and attention to
detail
hmm movies are very detailed and very
beautiful subtle little things in them
that really stand out how much of that
is detail and how much is luck I can go
I think they'll be a highly naked in a
pool table PS I thought the name to Luke
and tongues the true lies on the table
solutions so he died so he inquires in
the energy will be honest I thought the
titanium in your challenge one you saw
he journeyed certain things needed some
more collagen to source also time swiped
me so they tell my opinions and go home
wait out there and equipment ensues you
can show me how the room
NASA engineer sits in the open take away
data and we got the opposite Italian a
new journey and some of the
opportunities in scenario chance to do
it sounds delicious Italian the torso
challenge singing your total sentence
it's under single Cinco de pain Hawkins
au choix house to general consul Jang
Otto's house singing our Melbourne
partisan war rages TC gentle new niente
yo Satoru Sayama
in China son censored oito salmon salmon
NSO soda horses Oh Papa sueños de su
hijo wait on TAC one TAC one TAC Qantas
dakara nonde metal guitar one motion
Kanazawa to mojama horizontal metal rock
wanna touch Italian quando quando quando
Iraqi children
page true power choices so is what
touching DeWitt see how Authority you
take a country to resuscitate it's a
conscious and the steering the she want
to you just send Sunday on the province
and they eat the province and that
assault on grant approval is an
electoral approval under organs and
Jesus faith and vision
foods out here theta
Tom render sequence a tanuki toy faith
Fonseca very toys and the
intensity Jesus you have attained you
change the trees and to see Orsini ethos
is a sanctioned
maybe there is a new team with a Kawachi
you're the radiances and at some time
organs will cook vanishings to the pig
what and so can Resendez on Sunday
agreement amy has Danish in the same
member sunni book was the torso not you
not your estrogen so whole palace is
tied yeah because what happened
originally was I was boring man in China
and at the time I was popular or to go
to the fortune tellers so what the
fortune teller exactly said at the time
was that one day I would become an
important official and this is really
means for an official with thing that
government that's what the fortune
teller meant that would become a major
important official so I thought to my I
thought about this before like I didn't
really exactly become an official but I
thought to myself maybe becoming a
director that's real like a government
official in the sense that I could have
come show people I could get to manage
and and supervisor and things but just
talking about my filming career itself I
think I just want to emphasize the fact
that movie has been really worthwhile
for me because it's about human beings
it's dealing with the human characters
the human being sings on the camera and
I feel like humans are fascinating
they're wonderful they're interesting
they're moving they're compelling just
humanity itself is so beautiful and
compelling and I'm someone who
fundamentally believes in decency and
the compassion and the goodness of
people
so to want to continue to focus on human
beings to make them the subject of my
film that itself is an expression an act
of faith in the sense that I have faith
that human beings are fundamentally good
that no matter what happens even though
there's been a lot of prophecies and
prediction about how humanity you know
we're losing our basic decency we're
becoming worse and worse but I do
believe that at the end of the day we
are we have that capacity for good for
compassion for beauty and that self is
very moving to me and to be able to
capture that to be able to make movies
focusing on that that itself has been so
worthwhile to genre ginger yeah what
yeah as a kid has a contain your soul
contains this is auntie
or the here income sometimes is awakened
of a gentle the to this will be taught
oh say oh can you attain G Tomlinson
Fujita chose a 30 guitar New Jersey one
contained and touch even some who can't
you talk we talk we try the into the
Sanjana so Jeremy who in jumped I'll
have to interpret since top way to
manage talkin a way of young pinchy okay
don't write them the movies are very
moving for me because even to this day I
would watch movies in the theater on
television oftentimes I get profoundly
moved by the stuff I see because I feel
like movies are an expression of these
artists perception and perspective on
the world and it's an extension of that
for me to be able to behold that to be
able to watch that itself is moving so
movies are really a source of great
beauty and then profound sources of
covered unit people thank you thank you